[Musique]
quand j'étais jeune j'ai ré clic et le
monde ex des livres celui des 20 qu'il
avait livre jamais vous les livre à
cette époque c'est une nana
d'indéniables à cette époque e manche de
notre présent que de nerfs des chasseurs
guerriers prêts
[Musique]
j'ai eu la chance de marib au sulky - le
but d'intéresser et des sciences
techniques et de philippe may auteurs
les plus lus sur l'île qui vont être
décidées avait agi de ses idées inventer
une future salle enduits des grands
projets la science la culture
tout cela prend en mêlant des
mathématiques l'incroyable you loose ou
active un match en main les énergies
mais j'étais admiratif à cette épaule
admiratif devant le futur leur capacité
à changer les vérités de monde c'est
dans cette zone là je me suis posé la
question à ce moment
mais jenny rattrapé par effet de la
ville un jour traversent en moins de
trois ans à lyon
vous devenez vous rend à culoz itema le
net à me demander quel est l'intérêt de
ces hommes et de ces femmes avec au loin
de son pays allait y voit une jeune dame
lui entend j'en prends dix membres et
non raisonnée avec force et vigueur une
cdm gisant au sol genou vers une team de
bonne facture en 8 aux urgences elle a
peint une journée voire même diagnostic
et deux jouent aux parents d'être amis
ou leurs organes et non senti séquelles
physiques bien évidemment si biologique
et durable et mais ce que je sais moi
est content nous avons fait des nombres
et non morale dans la technologie
machine
et non la machine à cash
se pose alors une question qui commence
au mali bénin en sa compagnie a créé une
machine un ordinateur créer une autre
explosion et nous en consommons arriver
à créer la machine à bulles est doté
d'une intelligence énorme et d'une
puissance de calcul et maintenant
incapable avec des électrons
automatiquement que nous avons mêmes
déviance un fils yale
quand on peut venir aux autres
l'intelligence artificielle ça en ce
moment
un moyen de traiter le patient ce
principe a priori contre nature qui
permet d'injecter dans un élément
matériel
un ensemble vraiment molex éléments
statistiques et maintenant d'obinna
machine haute voix humaine
extraordinaire vous permet d et s'invite
façon in évidemment intéressant de voir
quelles sont ses revenus futurs que nous
invente en fait les éléments nous
vraiment de la santé dans notre futur
l'intelligence artificielle et s'annonce
comme un acteur prenne ont créé des
déchets les feux tricolores autonome
avec une régulation du trafic créer des
ambiances autre monde qu'il avait
organisé le transport des prénoms et
ville du futur et rose humanoïde capable
de voir avant tes lèvres mais aussi
d'avoir des blindes à une même famille
la façon de gérer ses enfants
l'assistance car l'intelligence
artificielle aux travaux madrid pourrait
nous permettre de lever une grande gêne
évidemment intelligence artificielle
s'invite et c'est là où est david en
amérique
pour les sonneries bull et no no limit
après une prescription médicale précise
devenus des habits stories est un
document médical le manque de
personnalisation dans le traitement de
patients
la non prise en compte des livres et
émotionnel avec moi médical le précis
possible et suivants bien évidemment les
marques émotionnelle du patient mais
quand on pas d'intelligence artificielle
ia l'epr il ya des images effrayantes
on se demande si les algorithmes
bon sinon intelligence surhumaine
on a le monde reut l'espèce humaine
ce sont des ce sont des craintes qui
verra son rosé élaborer des solutions
[Musique]
sur le chemin n'est pas absolu
d'embûches nous avons répandre et
sociologie ce natif financière a avancé
développement dans le domaine de la
santé où une manoeuvre utiliser et
romane hui à la formation de nos métiers
dans la façon elles reviennent au stick
en radio l'eau ode aux ventes une idée
qui s'inscrivent dans le futur et qui me
permet d'y voir améliorer nos conditions
d'existence développer des compétences
et ce chez mais aussi sur à part le
ghana personnes sensibles intelligence
artificielle et à ce que nous avons des
lieux pour le meilleur de nous mêmes et
vous aimez intelligence artificielle
nous d'avoir des connaissances et
d'ensuite elle nous amènera monnaie non
en biologie avec l'émotion 3d elle nous
amène à explorer autres costerousse
cette division
et créée à rome au travers les
indicateurs statistiques mais aussi des
techniques de l'enfoncement qui lui
permet notamment à rennes et c'est là où
les craintes se soulève
cet apprentissage pour comment mon
travail et de l'intelligence
artificielle va nous amener à vous une
face à denver
est-ce que s sur les utiliser avec temps
où est installé le 20 novembre
notre cerveau biologique est concluant
ses manigances artificielle 26 tués en
même temps que nous aujourd hui les
dirigeants sont artificielles elle
devenue une vraie mariable qui doit être
prise en compte par l'ensemble des
techniques en 2030 les nomme
l'enseignement sur un parti un terrain
de la médecine servicing optimisant
autre chose de vieux aux sciences au
personnaliser la transmission
la connaissance est aussi optimisée nive
et des monuments les délices en 2050 le
officier en débit est ce qu'elle va nous
inventer est moins nous amener end le
contrôle des insulines et la survie de
l'espèce et demandera de notre capacité
à garder une attache malienne location à
ce moment là se pose des questions
fondamentales humanité et cette question
d'ordre philosophique et ma technique
[Musique]
qu'est mouvement laisser aux générations
la wind it made in là ils sont ensemble
les mondes à cette question vitale cette
question complexe
il ya la ville de vienne ou à la science
heymans ans nous aurons a écrit
[Applaudissements]